Колективний імунітет довгий час здавався святим граалем у подоланні пандемії коронавірусу.
Імунологи сподівалися, що коли достатньо людей вироблять імунітет до "ковіду" -
шляхом щеплення чи інфікування - поширення вірусу сповільниться.
І щойно буде досягнуто поріг колективного імунітету, COVID-19 поступово зникне з нашого життя.
Принаймні один раз в історії людству вдалося досягти цього -
у випадку віспи, яку знищили за допомогою вакцин.
Але після двох років пандемії коронавірусу слід визнати: з "ковідом" цього не станеться.
Колективний імунітет нині здається наївною мрією перших днів пандемії.
Оскільки ми бачили всі ці мутації і ми все ще вивчаємо, наскільки ефективно може працювати здобутий імунітет,
нині справді важко сподіватися на досягнення колективного імунітету.
Якщо подолання вірусу за допомогою колективного імунітету більше не стоїть на порядку денному,
більш вірогідний варіант - те, що COVID-19 стане ендемічним.
Це означає, що вірус все ще поширюється в суспільстві, може поширюватися.
Але не так разюче і не на всіх.
Таким чином можна буде спостерігати більше чи менше спалахів
лише в певних групах населення або за певних умов.
Тому вплив на суспільство буде меншим, і це те, що ми називаємо ендемічним станом.
Ендемія означає, що загальна кількість випадків залишається стабільною, а тому передбачуваною.
Адже щеплення та попередні інфікування створили достатній імунітет, щоб зупинити неконтрольоване поширення.
Насправді людство живе з багатьма ендемічними хворобами.
Однією з них є грип. А ще - малярія та кір.
То яким би було наше життя з ендемічним "ковідом"?
Сценарій перший: коронавірус стане сезонним ризиком, який спалахує і спадає хвилями.
Так само, як грип.
Сценарій другий: коронавірус постійно присутній у певних групах населення по всьому світу,
але кількість випадків стабільна.
Сценарій третій: коронавірус стає дитячою хворобою, перше інфікування протікатиме найважче.
У літніх людей симптоми менш виражені через імунітет, отриманий через щеплення або попередні інфекції.
Деякі мої колеги думають, що "ковід" стане цілком звичайною хворобою.
Однією з багатьох. Це найбільш вірогідний сценарій.
Ми даватимемо з ним раду, як із грипом.
Отже, ми на порозі того, що пандемія стане ендемією?
Гадаю, з того, що ми нині спостерігаємо, зрозуміло, що ми ще не на ендемічній стадії.
Я бажав би, щоб до кінця 2022 року ми вийшли на ендемічну стадію цього інфекційного захворювання.
Але це залежить і від низки інших факторів - з боку самого збудника і з боку суспільства.
І якщо з'явиться новий патоген, або якщо збудник еволюціонує,
або якщо нам не вдасться вакцинувати стільки людей, скільки необхідно,
якщо ми змінимо нашу поведінку, все може піти інакше.
Ми не можемо бути певні.
Ендемія не означає, що хвороба більше не небезпечна.
Для деяких вона все ще може бути смертельною.
І це не обов’язково означатиме кінець усіх захисних заходів.
Візьмімо до прикладу малярію. Сон під москітними сітками або прийом протималярійних препаратів
є частиною заходів у боротьбі з цією хворобою.
Я сподіваюся, що ми винесемо уроки з цієї пандемії і збережемо деякі добрі речі, яких навчилися.
Наприклад, щороку тисячі людей помирали від грипу.
А тепер ми побачили, що за умов дотримання гігієнічних заходів, дистанції та носіння маски в людних місцях грип майже зник.
Тож ми, безумовно, могли б у майбутньому подумати про те, що деякі з цих заходів можуть залишатися доцільними.
Таким чином маски могли б залишатися частиною сезонної профілактики коронавірусу, навіть на ендемічній стадії.
Але поки що людству необхідно зосередити зусилля на тому,
щоб досягти цієї стадії - через вакцини та інфекційний контроль.